c'est l'histoire d'une petite île où il
est interdit de poser le pied
25 km² des rivages paradisiaque
nous sommes au beau milieu de l'océan
indien dans un territoire qui appartient
à lambres c'est là que s'est rendu john
ciao un américain de 27 ans la semaine
dernière
la dernière de ses nombreuses aventures
il a soudoyé des pêcheurs fini le trajet
en kayak
mais à peine était-il sur le sable qu'il
a été tué criblé de flèches
car lille n'est pas déserte ces images
sont les rares séquences où l'on voit la
tribu des sentinelles l'un des seul
peuple qui vit totalement recul jusque
dans les années 90 le gouvernement
indien a tenté d'entrer en contact
à chaque fois la même hostilité ils
seraient les descendants directs de
population parties d'afrique
il y à 60 mille ans
après le tsunami de 2004 en indonésie
des garde-côtes survolent l'île pour
voir si la tribu a survécu ce qui donne
lieu à ce face à face un homme qui tente
d'abattre l'hélicoptère avec son arc et
ses flèches
selon les ong survival il est essentiel
de rester à l'écart pour leur éviter des
maladies
quant aux touristes américains qui vient
de payer de sa vie une tentative de
contact
[Musique]
c'était déjà arrivé comment est ce qu il
a pu croire que ça se passerait
autrement
l'équipage d'un cargo hong kong et avait
vécu une semaine d'angoise avant d'être
secourue à l'été 1981 quand leur navire
a échoué dans le récif de corail
le seul contact positif remonte à 1991
quand un anthropologue est parvenu à
leur offrir des noix de coco depuis plus
rien deux pêcheurs avait été tué en 2006
on estime très vaguement que les
sentinelles sont entre 40 et 400 ici
mathieu prost radio-canada à montréal